and joining us now dr vivek murthy
former surgeon general and co-chair of
the biden transition
coveted task force doctor the the latest
numbers on the covid surge are deeply
alarming
let's take a look at some of them more
than a hundred eighty four thousand
new cases just on friday that's up
seventy six percent over the past two
weeks
more than sixty eight thousand people
now in hospitals
and more than 1400 deaths friday
question what's going on what's causing
this
really troubling surge
well chris you're right that we are at
an alarming phase of this pandemic and
these are staggering numbers that
we never really thought we would see in
terms of cases and hospitalizations
not to mention the overall death toll
but what's happening is that
a couple of things one is we never
really got our caseload down
to a level that was truly manageable in
the spring and we didn't actually have
the testing and contact tracing to
prevent subsequent rises in infection
but what's happening now in particular
is that with winter as people move
indoors
this is actually the perfect setup for
the virus because we know it likes it's
easier to spread indoors and outdoors
but there's one last component here
which is really important which is
pandemic fatigue
now people are tired we've been at this
pandemic now for many months
and i get that but part of that fatigue
means that people are letting others
into their bubble they're getting
together
for in-person dinner parties for game
nights and public health departments are
now tracing more and more cases back
to these kind of gatherings so you put
this all together and you see the
explosive spread
that we have so
what is the trump administration
doing wrong at this point given that a
lot of this just seems to be
uh baked into the cake and what
specifically and i mean specifically
will the biden administration do better
well there are few things for us to
think about in terms of addressing the
current surge
one thing i really want to emphasize is
that when you get to
numbers that are this bad the most
immediate thing that we can do
to reduce the spread it actually lies in
our behavior
in the choices that we make it turns out
that wearing masks
keeping our distance from others washing
our hands these
seem almost too simple but they're very
powerful in actually reducing this
spread
but what vice president what
president-elect biden
is uh is has talked about in terms of
his plan what he wants to do differently
what he wants to emphasize for day one
is really a plan that focuses on
expanding our testing capacity so that
we can
do better surveillance testing and
diagnostic testing but also increase our
contact tracing force so that we can
contain infection once we find it
he wants to increase the production of
ppe or protective equipment or
healthcare workers all have masks and
gloves when they need it
and he wants to really put clear
guidance together evidence-based
guidance
so that schools and businesses but also
faith organizations youth sports leagues
and families
know how to operate safely chris
thoughton i should just say one more
important thing here which is that none
of this is going to be possible
if we don't rebuild public trust that's
really the most important foundation
here
the way you do that is by communicating
honestly by leading with science and
scientists in the face of this pandemic
and ultimately by delivering results
is the delay in the transition because
president trump is contesting the
election
is that delay hurting the ability of the
biden
administration to take over on january
20th
in dealing with the covid pandemic
well it's very important chris for the
transition to be able to talk to
the the existing administration and the
reason is that there are
thousands and thousands of career civil
servants
political appointees who have been
working very hard on this pandemic
for many months now they have plans that
are in process they have
data that they've collected that the
public doesn't always have access to and
to be able to see that data
see those plans it's what's going to
help us put together the best possible
product in the end so those dialogues
are critical uh
there you want to get them started as
soon as possible and there's a lot of
work for us to do now still even though
we don't have access
to the departments but we're going to
need that as soon as possible
to make this all work well
one of the big questions of course is
whether the country
is going to have to engage in another
lockdown one of your colleagues
on the covid task force the biden
coveted task force talked
this week about a possible four to six
week national
lockdown and president trump responded
to that take a look
we can pay people to lose their jobs we
can pay small businesses
we can take care of city state and
county governments
this administration will not be going to
a lockdown hopefully the
the whatever happens in the future who
knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell but
uh i can tell you this administration
will not go to a lockdown
now president-elect biden says he's not
thinking of a national lockdown one of
your colleagues on the task force said
this weekend you're thinking not of an
on off switch but more of a dimmer
having said that the governor of new
mexico just issued a two-week
stay-at-home measure the governor of
oregon is talking about a partial
two-week lockdown can't you honestly say
if things get bad enough aren't we going
to need
a national lockdown well that's a
measure of last resort chris and i'm
glad you raised this because
the way we think about lockdowns i think
is different now than it was in the
spring
in the spring when we didn't know a lot
about covet we responded
in a sense with an on off switch we we
just shut things down because you know
we didn't know exactly how this was
spreading and where it was spreading
we've learned a lot more since then that
tells us that the better way to think
about these safety restrictions
is more as a dial that we turn up and
down depending on severity
and that's really the key here is
applying this these restrictions
judiciously and precisely if you look in
new york city for example
they're applying not broad restrictions
everywhere but looking at
specific zip codes to see where the
outbreak is is severe
what we need chris and the reason that
you see so much of variation
and what states are doing is that we
don't have a national alert system
guided by the best possible evidence
that can help states and localities
determine when to dial up and down these
restrictions
and we also don't have adequate
resources for them to put
these restrictions in place namely
schools for example which still don't
have
resources to expand class sizes hire
more teachers and improve ventilations
if we just lock down the entire country
without targeting our efforts
that we are going to exacerbate the
pandemic fatigue people are feeling we
are going to hurt jobs in the economy
we are going to shut down schools and
hurt the education of our children
so we've got to approach this with the
precision of a scalpel rather than the
the blunt force of an axe
then there is the issue of the vaccine
which seems to be
making remarkable progress president
trump
talked on friday about getting it out as
quickly as possible
starting perhaps even in december but
then
he's talked about governor cuomo of new
york
who has said that he wants to check any
vaccine
the trump administration delivers take a
look
he doesn't trust the fact that it's this
white house this administration so
we won't be delivering it to new york
until we have authorization to do so
what do you think of president trump's
statements
singling out new york for a delay in the
vaccine
and how does the biden
transition administration plan to deal
one with getting out the vaccine and
also
dealing with the issue of people's
concern
about the safety the reliability of
actually getting vaccinated
well chris you're you're bringing up one
of the most challenging parts
of this pandemic response which is how
to deliver
that vaccine you know we vaccinated
americans for many years
you know in our country but the campaign
we're going to have to build
to vaccinate enough people to create
herd immunity in america will be the
most ambitious
vaccination campaign i believe in our
country's history
and doing that requires people to trust
that that vaccine is
safe and that it's effective
unfortunately we know from recent polls
that a significant number of people are
worried
that the process of developing the
vaccine and proving it may have been
politicized so
now the onus is on us to be as
transparent and possible
in helping them understand what the
science does say having experts
review the data making that data readily
available so that even people outside
the government can review it
that's what we're going to have to do
and ultimately the way we allocate this
vaccine
has to be determined based on need
and that and that alone we can't afford
to let politics creep in
to decisions we make around the vaccine
because otherwise we're going to put
lives at stake
dr murthy thank you thanks for your time
this weekend and we'll of course be
tracking the work of your task force
well thank you so much chris it's really
good to be with you today